we're on 121
121
it says if x over 2
x over 2
is equal to
3
over y
is x
less than
y
so let's just try to so this is
essentially saying that x times y
x times y is equal to 6. i just cross
multiplied or you could do that step by
step multiply both sides by 2 then
multiply both sides by y and you get x y
is equal to 6 and they want to know
whether x is less than y statement 1
says
y is greater than
y is greater than or equal to
3.
okay if y is greater than or equal to 3
so what does that mean so let's think
about this
x is equal to
6 divided by y
right if y is greater than or equal to
three
so if if it's three that's the largest
that x can be right if y is three if y
is any larger number then x will only be
smaller so x will be
less than or equal to
6 over 3 or x will be less than or equal
to 2.
and and just i want you to understand
why i said that think about this it says
y is greater than or equal to 3 if y is
3
x is going to be 2. if y is 4
x is going to be 1 and a half
if y is 6 x is going to be 1. so the
highest value for x happens when y is
equal to 3 and then as y gets larger and
larger x just gets smaller so x
y being greater than or equal to 3 says
that x
is less than or equal to 2. so statement
1 alone is sufficient to say that x is
less than y
right if x is less than 2 and y is
greater than 3 then x is definitely less
than y
statement 2 tells us
y is less than or equal to 4.
y is less than or equal to 4. so this is
interesting this is
it's really just the inverse of of this
statement right here now you're saying
instead of y being greater than a
certain number y is less than a certain
number so if you think about it this way
so let's just go back to this
equation
so
x is going to be if y is 4
x is going to be
x is going to be
so when y let's do a little table
y
x
if y is equal to four
x is equal to one point five
if y is equal to three
x is equal to two
if y is equal to two then x is equal to
three
so actually this constraint i can pick a
bunch of different y's that meet this
constraint
but it still doesn't tell me about
anything whether x is greater than or
less than y here x is less than y
and here x is greater than y so this
statement is useless so statement one
alone is sufficient to answer this
question and statement two doesn't help
us much
122.
if v and w are different integers does v
equals zero
does v equal zero
different integers remember it says
different okay they say that v
w
is equal to
is equal to v
squared
vw is equal to
v squared now let's think about this if
this doesn't tell me for sure that
v is equal to zero and in fact as long
as well let's think about this the only
way that this could be true
is if v is equal to zero
that's one case now v does not equal to
zero
so if we assume that's one k so if v
does not equal to zero
then this case implies what
that that w equals v think about it if v
doesn't equal zero we can divide both
sides by v because we know we're not
dividing by zero you divide both sides
by v you get on the left hand side w
because this v cancels out and then v
squared divided by v
you get v
right
and so you are left with
well i want to be careful here though
because
because right now w would have to equal
v
right and they already told us that w
and v are two different numbers so we
know that this
this situation
right if w equals v then v does not
equal zero right but they tell us in the
problem statement that w and v are two
different integers they tell us that w
does not equal v
so we know that v that the only way that
this could be satisfied if w does not
equal v
is if v is equal to zero
so statement one alone is sufficient to
answer this question
statement two
w is equal to two
w is equal to two well that doesn't do
anything for me
i mean w could be two and v could be
zero or v could be three
they all they told us was that v and w
are different integers and that they
don't equal each other so this doesn't
help me at all in determining whether v
is equal to zero so statement one alone
is sufficient
i just want to make sure i got that
first part right i mean the only way
that this is true this is true v is
equal to zero or it's true if w is equal
to v
either of those cases
are true
right that's the only way it works
and we know w does not equal v so v has
to be equal to zero
state what are we on 123.
123.
what is the value of
36500 36500
times
1.05
1.05
to the nth power
all right statement number one tells us
n squared
minus five n
plus six is equal to zero
so we could solve for n there'll be two
solutions so this is n
minus two
times n
minus 3. i just factor it i said what
two numbers when i multiply them equal
positive six so i said minus two minus
three and when you add them become minus
five that's why i picked the minuses as
opposed to plus two and plus three or
some other combination
equals zero so statement one tells us
that n is equal to 2
or n is equal to 3.
so statement 1 by itself isn't enough
because i don't know whether i should
put a 2 here or 3 here so i can't
determine this value just yet
statement 2 tells us n
n minus 2 does not equal
0.
this statement by itself is is fairly
useless because it just tells me this
just tells me that n does not equal 2 so
n could be any other number so i don't
know what number to put here but use in
conjunction these two statements
statement one says n is either two or
three statement two says well it's not
two so if you use both of these together
we know that n is equal to three and
then we could obviously solve this
problem taking 1.05 to the third power
and multiplying by 36
500 which i won't do because it would be
a waste of time
124
124
and the rectangular coordinate system
above well let me draw that let's see
they have
the y-axis
they have the x-axis
then they draw on a triangle i'll do it
in a different color like that
like that
and the letters
are
o
p
and q
and the rectangular coordinate system
above if o p is less than p q
so o p is less than p q let me write
that down o p is less than
p
q
is the area of
o p q greater than 48 so we want to know
is area
greater than 48 o p is less than p q so
the way i drew this actually isn't isn't
right it's probably a little bit shifted
to the left a little bit but fair enough
we can visualize we can imagine that
so let's see statement number one the
coordinates
coordinates of point p are six comma
eight
so this is six
comma eight
so let's see that tells us
that tells us the height right when we
figure out the area of a triangle we
need to know the base
times the height and then multiply that
times one half this tells us that the
height because the height of this
triangle is the y-coordinate which is
eight
right so the altitude of this triangle
is eight so we have the height but we
still don't know the distance from o to
q that's
so statement one by itself isn't isn't
much information so that tells us that
the point was 6 8 that p was 6 8.
statement 2 says the coordinates of
point q are 13 comma 0.
13. well this is helpful 13 comma 0. so
this distance right here is 13
so by itself that's useless because if i
didn't have the height i still wouldn't
be able to figure out the area of this
triangle but now if i use both
statements i know the base times the
height so the area is going to be the
base times the height times one half so
eight times one half is four times 13 is
52
and so 52 is clearly greater than 48.
let me make sure that because i didn't
use this information
i didn't use that information at all
but it doesn't
let's see let me think about it
let me think about it actually no i
think i've i'm wrong i think statement
one alone might be enough let's assume
that we don't have
see these are tricky let's assume that
we don't have statement two there
let me see if i can figure out whether
the area is greater than 48 without it
let me see yeah i think i'm wrong let me
yeah i caught myself
okay so if this is
if this is six comma eight
the area of this triangle right here
well this distance right here is going
to be six
right
there this distance right here is six
six comma eight right okay so
the area of this triangle is six times
eight
48 times one half so the area of this
triangle is 24 right
but they told us that op is less than pq
that this distance
is less than this distance maybe i
should draw it like that so you can kind
of see it
and the only way that this distance is
less than this distance
is if
this distance
is less than this distance ah this is a
tricky problem right this has to be less
than this
right q has to be further away because
that's the only way you're going to get
this altitude to be longer than this
altitude right because you're assuming
that q is along the axis so that's the
only thing that you can shift back and
forth
so if this distance is larger than this
distance then the area of this triangle
is going to be at least 24 so the area
is going to be greater than
48.
so actually
all you needed was statement 1 to solve
this problem
that's all you needed statement 1 gave
you enough information statement 2 does
not by itself give you enough
information because you don't know how
high p is it could be really low down
here because the area is going to be
less than 48 it could be really high in
which case the air would be greater than
48 but anyway see i i almost got that
one wrong but i'll leave you there i'll
see in the next video that statement one
alone was sufficient for this one see
you soon